let's jump to this story which is uh oh
so spicy we got this one from the daily
mail before I'd read the headline I just
want to say do not take medical advice
from podcasters talk to trusted medical
professionals about what's right for you
because the Daily Mail says getting
Pfizer's covid booster and flu vaccine
on the same day May raise the risk of a
stroke FDA says the FDA says it okay the
FDA the Food and Drug Administration
found the preliminary link while
scouring vaccine injury databases after
a separate safety concern was raised
about Pfizer's jab earlier this month
one of the country's vaccine
surveillance systems flagged a possible
association between the Omicron specific
shot and an elevated risk of ischemic
stroke among seniors over 65. FDA
officials who have been investing in the
link said most of the patients had also
received their flu shot on the same day
which might be a factor millions of
Americans got both shots at the same
time this winter following a major
public health Push by the White House in
September Dr Ashish Jah White House
coveted response coordinator said quote
I believe this is why God gave us two
arms one for the flu shot and the other
for the covet shot oh yo wait a minute I
mean this I don't know if this is
definitively the cause of why we're
hearing about more Strokes why more
excess death or heart attacks but the
White House was telling people to get
both they it's quoted and the FDA is now
saying there may be a link here so
I don't know I guess how long do you
think it'll be until they come out and
definitively be like oh yeah about all
that that was that was that was correct
so like is the FDA wrong right now to
suggest this I'll I'll frame it that way
for our friends over at YouTube at least
they put it out there I mean I do think
we're in this this uh this weird space
right now where I think our ruling
classes realize they got this whole
covid thing completely and totally wrong
but because of you know Pride them
worrying about like any kind of
repercussions but then also just the
whole sunken cost fallacy like you
continue to double down it's really hard
to say you know what we got this wrong
especially since we were so harsh on all
the random people out there who said I
have questions I don't know if I want to
do that this is funny because it's like
a it's a it's a casino dad joke when you
lose a bet you go well you know what
they say when you lose a bet just gamble
twice as much because you're not
supposed to do this
that's right and uh this is kind of
crazy for me to see the story I mean we
had so many crazy stories just come out
in the past couple of hours when we
started the show and what what had
happened was uh I think was a couple
weeks ago they said that they found a
potential signal between I think it was
Strokes I think it was Strokes I'm not
sure there was a signal between vaccines
and some negative side effect but
they're not sure if it was actually
correct now it looks like they're saying
the FDA is saying this
that they went in and they started
looking and said hey wait a minute maybe
it's because people are getting the both
these shots at the same time
yeah that could explain a lot I mean I
feel like the FDA wouldn't come out and
even give a potentially there's maybe
something there unless they had to right
like they don't want to seed any
territory on this front it's not just
that I mean imagine you work for the FDA
and you're sitting there looking at this
document that says this thing and you're
thinking I'm gonna lose my job at the
advisor when I retire from the FDA if I
put this report out but you really have
no choice yeah and the crazy thing is
like the vaccine if this was any other
vaccine or booster I think they would
say hey wait stop we don't know what's
going on here let's let's you know have
a pause let's study it but because
they've invested so much in it right now
all we get is these like kind of
willy-nilly warnings because it's the
sacred coveted vaccine well I I have I
half agree with uh Johnson and Johnson
and AstraZeneca yeah they did put a stop
on those because I think what was it
AstraZeneca was the blood clot one yeah
actually I think and then Johnson
Johnson was blood clots but it was only
the one dose and there were other like
core morbidities that were yeah that
like the US doesn't have astrozanic I'm
pretty sure and then I did you want to
fact check this one I'm pretty sure the
US they said hey we're going to put a
pause on the Johnson and Johnson one
because of a risk of blood clotting or
something like that and then uh uh WebMD
I think it is
and the American Heart Association have
come out and said that there is that
myocarditis is a rare side effect of the
MRNA vaccines so it seems like a lot of
the fears people had early on
are now just basically being affirmed by
powerful institutions and and health
organizations that being said I will
stress they also add their extremely
rare side effects but they do find these
links so I want to make sure people
don't look I know a lot of people are
outright either people are like either
everyone must be vaccinated or totally
anti-vaxx it's like it's it's fine to be
somewhere in the middle and just be like
look talk to a doctor
covet could be causing this it could be
a combination of things it could be like
you said they've invested too heavily in
this and they won't back down Johnson
Johnson uh pulled or the U.S pulled
Johnson Johnson because of a link to
blood clots in December 2021 and then
AstraZeneca was paused in Europe by a
bunch of different countries in uh May
of 2022. I think uh isn't some country
stopping the vaccine the MRNA vaccine
for other people under 29 was that
Sweden or something
one of those Scandinavian countries well
you there was a whole wave of countries
that paused uh Cove vaccines I think it
was Pfizer specifically but for young
men because they saw the link to
myocarditis and all the heart issues and
then they kept raising it it went from
being like Oh well 12 to 18 and then it
I think in some countries it went all
the way up to like 45. we we got a
problem with this if the FDA is really
putting the story out because if they're
saying that a combination of vaccines
can cause problems then we've got to
have an inquiry on have we done studies
on the combination of all vaccines that
I don't think I don't think you really I
think it's very difficult to do this if
the conditions were different I don't
think that there's any question about
the fact that the FDA would be like stop
everything stop you can't put this out
blah blah blah Etc I think that that
that goes without saying the reason that
they're so tentative about this is
because they've for so long were pushing
so hard and demonize the population and
called people all the names that you
could possibly imagine yeah and and now
they're like oh oh well because they've
already destroyed their credibility and
they think that they're defending you
from terrible conspiracy theorists right
saying like well we can't give up this
front because then the conspiracy
theorists have won and they'll they'll
tell you all sorts of horrible things it
actually reminds me of conversations
people have about
um
preservatives and Foods right like if
you eat store manufactured food or
whatever all day you're actually putting
a ton of stuff into your body you don't
know about I don't know anything about
it really but like it is something you
wonder I can only imagine putting lots
of different types of vaccines that you
can't in a consistent way test their
interactions it's a gamble oh well I you
can test our interactions it's just a
question of have we well and also like
you can't it would be difficult to
reproduce study after study after study
that are able to consistently test let's
uh let's talk about the the actual
challenge here I mean the permutations
of vaccine combination combinations is
probably in the in the billions or
trillions so we actually do have a
challenge in this idea of of Health
technology
we make vaccines most of the vaccines
that people get have been tested and
tried out for decades we seem to be
doing all right I I've gotten a whole
bunch of crazy shots when I was
traveling the world yeah I'm totally
okay and so I know there's a lot of
people who are like staunchly anti-backs
we had Candace Owens on she she talked
about this on the members only show she
gave her her opinions on this but the
question is every time we come out with
a new medication we it would be
impossible to I'm not I'm not even not
even vaccines but any drug any drug so
let's say they come out of the new
painkiller they're gonna have to test
what happens if someone's on this
painkiller and Drug a drug B drug C drug
D drug e drug f I mean the combinations
are going to be in the in ridiculous
numbers
now they do have like counter
indications like hey don't take this if
you're taking this so to to the best of
their abilities they do track the stuff
but for the most part it seems what
happens is
they give someone a painkiller the
person's also on a blood thinner they
then see the person have a negative
reaction they then you know track this
and say hey over the past thousand
combinations of this drugs we saw
negative reactions let's so it's it's
like the the the studies are happening
in real time essentially I think I guess
what I'm trying to say is
any attempt we're gonna have at making
drugs or medical technology is going to
run into side effect problems it is and
and how we navigate that stuff I don't
know I think just being honest I mean
that I think the reason why we're seeing
so many people now that are outright
like militant anti-vaxxers is because
we've just they've been lying to us
about so many different things regarding
covid from the beginning that now it's
gone the completely different direction
where people are just like I don't want
any more vaccines I don't trust anything
you guys are saying and that's pretty
dangerous because I think if like a real
legit lethal virus hit the U.S Shores
Tomorrow there's a lot of people
probably myself included that would be
like I don't believe you I'm not going
to take that we talked about a few years
ago Ian brought up a really great point
we were all like no lockdowns lockdowns
are wrong and he said what if it was an
Airborne Ebola yeah and then we're like
okay that's an interesting point but you
know ultimately the conclusion we came
to was like if you choose to go out
during a pandemic it's your choice and
if you don't want to stay inside lock
your doors but there is an interesting
question I'd have right
a lot of people are essentially
anti-vaxx but my question legitimately
maybe I'll do a pause I don't know if I
can phrase it get enough characters to
make a pull on this one but
people are you know people have gotten
coveted some people have said it's not
that bad some people have said it was
pretty bad some people said it was
apocalyptically bad for me it was
nightmarishly bad it was the worst
illness I've ever gotten I've had the
flu before and I was pale and shaking
yeah I got coveted I actually called the
hospital oh really yeah yeah because I
it was bad my my temperature was really
low my breathing was very heavy and I it
was pain all over and then I ended up
getting monoclonal antibodies I've told
the story a million times my question is
this for the people who are not trusting
of the government if you actually
witnessed people
suffering Ebola symptoms like you walk
outside in the streets and people have
blood coming out of their eyes and
they're hacking up black and they're
going on they're falling over
and then the government came in a truck
and they were like we've got the vaccine
quick you need to get it now would you
guys accept it well think of it
I just think there's been so much trust
burned that you would have to see I mean
people nowadays not not everybody but I
think there would be a significant
portion of our population who would be
like I don't care if you put it on the
news I need to see it with my own eyes
until then I think you guys are screwing
me no no that's what I mean let's say
you personally yeah saw people outside
hacking up black and bleeding from their
eyes and then slumping over and
convulsing and then a truck pulls up and
they come out and they say Mr Kent we've
got vaccines for you in your
neighborhood please come we're going to
administer administer them to you would
you say okay to that yeah I think at
that point yeah it makes sense it's
tough though it is still a hard question
some people would say no I understand
why they say no they'd be like dude I
don't know what's going on I mean in in
um where was it Nigeria where was the
Ebola thing happening do you remember
that a few years ago yeah it's like near
Congo so people were running from the
doctors yeah and they and and the
doctors are trying to stop the spread of
Ebola and the people like I don't trust
you and so they would flee and then
actually spread Mori Bola yeah it's it's
hot it's a tough situation yeah I think
that I think that the situation would
really boil down to the you know the
context if you're like if you're looking
at people that are you know vomiting
blood and stuff the risk is probably far
greater of dying from that than from a
uh a vaccine the reason people are are
worked up about covet is because covid
for a lot of people was not as was not
deadly if you were in good health and
you didn't have you know uh with the
contributing factors and stuff and
that's right part of why people were
upset it's like I had to take this these
have risks I was healthy or I am healthy
I probably wouldn't have a problem you
know I kind of feel like uh the the
highest risk demographic was the older
people people with comorbidities so it
really does feel like politicians who
are scared for themselves told everyone
else they have to do it yeah so that
they would be better off yeah I mean
I've known people that's how like some
young moms get told they need to get the
flu vaccine right they'll say like
there's a bad flu out break in our city
and you have a newborn baby and if you
don't pass down like you're
breastfeeding or whatever the antibodies
for it then your baby is at risk and an
infant at this age can't handle the flu
right and so they get the flu vaccine
not saying there's anything wrong with
flu vaccine I'm just giving it as an
example uh when maybe they would have
opted not to because they felt like they
are actually protecting someone else I
think that's how the government sold to
a lot of people if you have elderly
parents do you want to be the one that
gave them covid right or do you want to
be kept away from them like it put
people in a really difficult position
and unfortunately covet was not a
clear-cut example of who of how bad the
symptoms were right like if someone's
vomiting a black goo and I'm always like
okay I guess I'm in but like right you
know there's a limit right but also like
a really bad fever can be extremely
dangerous right a high in a fever you
can have seizures so there are things
that look that aesthetically don't look
as bad but they are all so uh terrible
and can be devastating the reason I
bring this up before we go on to the
next story is
we just we just Pro we had this project
Veritas expose of a guy who is either a
consultant working at Pfizer director or
a director advisor saying that he
believes the Wuhan lab leak is likely
where this came from because covet
couldn't have come from somewhere else
or whatever that's his opinion
in the in the in in 2020 this was the
big Theory people were saying that they
believed it was a bioweapon leak from a
lab yeah if that theory were true then
it makes more sense that the governments
of the world in panic desperately tried
to make a vaccine to stop a bioeconomic
from a lab in which case the vaccine it
makes sense why they're like you have to
take this yeah because you think about
this way they're you know fauci is
providing this funding the lab the the
lab leak thing happens and then he's
probably going like oh man oh that thing
I made is getting everywhere we got to
get a vaccine everybody's got to take it
that makes that makes a lot of sense to
me and then if people are having blood
clots and other weird you know problems
it makes more sense Occam's razor would
suggest that covet is causing these
things and not the vaccines because what
you'd have to believe then
is if you think it was the vaccines
causing it that Not only was covet a Buy
open leak from a lab but then after it
released they went now let's make
everything a whole lot worse okay so
then it's not a lab leak it's an
intentional release and a fake look I'm
not saying I know for sure one way or
the other I'm just saying it's it's way
more Fantastical to believe that yeah
but I don't know I just don't know right
and and I can only say this
there's no functional official narrative
like the average person just not
trusting of the government at this point
because the stories just do not work for
people so the only thing I can really
say is do what uh be like Joe Rogan find
a medical professional that you trust
that can answer your questions and then
you know like I always mentioned I
called Joe I always have to shout Joe
out because they dragged him so much for
this when his whole position was like I
called the doctor and asked them what to
do because their position was going to
the 7-Eleven parking lot yeah yeah I
mean for real thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time